neil has finally done an experiment for
me that I really wanted to see for many
many years
a teaspoon dissolving or melting in a
cup of tea I thought that in joke shops
you could buy a spoon like this that
melted in tea and I've been to some of
the leading magic shops in the UK and
found nothing and then a miracle
happened one of our viewers sent us a
low melting point alloy I went out and
bought Neil a mold for making spoons
it's actually meant for chocolate but it
worked for this metal then there were
all sorts of delays and yesterday we
finally decided we should do the
experiment but we've lost the letter so
we don't know chemically what the metal
spoon is but we decided we'd go ahead
anyway and I'm going to have to analyse
the spoon to find out what it is
all these metals that melt at low
temperature are so-called
alloys they're mixtures of different
metals which don't crystallize very well
so at low temperature you can melt them
much lower temperature than the
individual metals and they usually
contain led sometimes 10 sometimes
cadmium sometimes indium and they're
named after the people that have
discovered them there's rose alloy which
melts at 98 degrees which I think's a
bit higher than the temperature that Nia
was using I don't think his tea was
actually boiling then there is woods
metal at 70 degrees and there's fields
metal at 62 degrees centigrade Celsius
if you prefer which of strong candidates
I seem to remember that the fan who sent
us the letter said that the metal
contained indium and if it did is
probably fields metal but we'll have to
test the chocolate mold that I had made
a sort of spoon but it didn't look quite
as nice as we would have liked
so I encouraged Neal to hammer the spoon
to look nicer but whatever this alloy is
it's very hard and brittle and
eventually he dumped it so hard that it
broke so he had to recast it so our
spoon is not terribly spoon like
[Music]
but what's interesting is that as he
lowered it into the tea and she did it
properly there was a tea bag though he
didn't taste the tea as he load it in it
quickly melted and disappeared
and at the bottom the molten metal
looked very like mercury it's not
mercury but of course most metals are
silver or many of them and any silvery
liquid metal will look rather like
mercury
when Neil decanted the tea leaving the
metal the metal quickly solidified again
because it cooled down I think the metal
is quite toxic but I don't think any of
it will dissolve this is melting not
dissolving just as well or we would have
lost our alloy and would never been able
to analyze it easily it was really nice
to watch it doesn't have a great
scientific purpose but sometimes there's
some scientific phenomena that you've
read about and you'd really like to see
with your own eyes
so saying this was really quite exciting
[Music]
you